he owns Twitter and flies to space but
haters only see his race yeah the Press
says pre-teen Elon was a terrible fella
because he didn't free Nelson Mandela
that was a pretty good rhyme since Elon
Musk outbid me and bought Twitter
a terrified media will stop at nothing
to label him a racist like a parrot with
a head wound they keep repeating
themselves mostly about crackers
get it
here are some headlines CNN says Elon
musk's possible takeover of Twitter is
unsettling for many black users Rolling
Stone Elon Musk previews what he'll do
with Twitter serves up his employees for
far rights racist abuse LA Times with
Elon Musk in charge it's the beginning
of the end for black Twitter and there's
this one from highlights
[Laughter]
Goofus loves Elon Gallant not so much
I figured somebody in the audience would
get that come on who didn't read
highlights shut up cat and then there's
the New York Times which tweeted Elon
Musk grew up in Elite white communities
in South Africa detached from
apartheid's atrocities and surrounded by
anti-black Propaganda
but if you actually read the article you
find out that musk had black friends it
was bullied for standing up to racist
children plus he fled from South Africa
when he was 17. yes at least Elon left
his all-white Community how many times
readers can say the same thing even
elon's mother stepped in tweeting in
South Africa if you publicly oppose
apartheid you went to jail in Russia if
you publicly opposed the war you go to
jail New York Times are you going to
blame children for decisions made by
governments way to go mom Elon better
get her something nice for Mother's Day
why not buy her the New York Times
I don't think they could cancel this guy
he's too rich Kennedy like I mean he's
not like you know a normal person it's
like he could do like if they come after
him he'll just buy them
when you make rockets and you're sending
human beings to Mars you have proven
that you have Fu money and you don't
care you will build something or you
will buy something cooler even if it's
just to distract yourself or soothe your
own feelings did we learn nothing from
Brett Kavanaugh and his mom is
absolutely right you cannot blame him
for whom he was born to or where he was
born because the second you have the
choice to leave that's when you're an
adult and he made that choice he left he
didn't go back this is an entirely
manufactured Story by people who have no
personal experience in South Africa and
who really don't understand his life or
where he's from it is an imposition
trying to create a perception just like
defund the police it is overly
simplistic and ultimately harm thankful
you know I it's we talked about this
yesterday cat complaining that musk like
will make Twitter worse it's like saying
an autopsy must really hurt the corpse
yeah I I mean how can you get actually
make Twitter where Twitter makes me I I
go it's like I'm a hypocrite because I
go I am a thank you you are a hypocrite
yeah you tell me all the time you were
like don't read your mentions because
you don't need to see all that and then
I see you late into the night quote
tweeting everyone who's me why do you go
but you give away all your materials I
wouldn't have anything to write in my
books or anything if I'm giving it away
every day Twitter is a place where you
don't get paid for anything you say but
you can get fired for it I don't get on
Facebook I'm not interested in what you
had for lunch I mean you know but it's
it's it's it's bad and it's again it's
not that not that many people are even
on it like the vast majority of the
population is not even on Twitter so
even if he's some how made it worse
which I don't know like how you would uh
it wouldn't affect most people they're
like the Democracy itself is gonna
crumble like like do you listen to yours
like calm down you know I hope he buys
the you know the big new Marilyn Monroe
painting that's going to break all the
records everything made sell for half a
billion dollars I hope he gets that
that'll make people soon
if I had that kind of money I would
purposely try to buy things that upset
people well because I know nothing about
sports so I would buy the Yankees and
just drive it into the ground
I don't know I don't know anything I
don't know anything about sports either
and I was the Nike ad this year
no one has ever thrown me a ball in my
life I mean
are you sure yeah even my dad gave up
you know
yeah my dad stopped going to the games
sad digging but I I do get everybody's
outrage I I you know I like the New York
Times I know I'm that's a terrible thing
to say here they just gave my book a
great review so I'm really proud of you
500 but I understand the rage I get why
people are so pissed off because this is
a story I have a black fun and Baldwin
she said a guy at work said to her
what's your a bank routing number and
she said why and he said I just want to
send you something and he sent her 50
she said what's this for he said you
know what slavery you know I mean she
was so outraged
what he said you know
see I understand that a rage and that's
why I think Jet Magazine should come out
now as a hipster black magazine that
makes fun of Clueless white reactions to
Black lives matter ah I think that would
be great I love jet remember that right
it was it was a downscale but they also
specialized in publishing Aretha
Franklin's outfits that she designed for
herself which were truly atrocious so
that was like this big and it was always
at the front at the liquor store and
then we had Readers Digest and and
Prevention magazine it was very strange
back but it sold huge amounts of copies
we had very different magazines at our
liquor store oh yeah
no I mean it was like jugs with three
G's like it was yeah and that was that
was amazing I miss the old magazine rack
I do too I have one in my house every
magazine looks like a dentist office but
now I go on airplanes and I always have
like it used to have like a hundred
dollars magazines you want some people
act like I handed them a turd we're
gonna talk about that in the next block
yeah
so taken he hasn't done anything yet he
hasn't and people are freaking out what
if what if nothing happens what if
nothing changes this is all for nothing
uh it's well it's not all for nothing
the New York Times clearly ran that
photo to kind of troll him to show his
well when he had real hair yes when it
wasn't like a system yes
number one number two where in the hell
have they been for the last 20 years he
has built a giant robot army of
automobiles yes that are remote control
they're like two million of these robots
out there and he's shooting into space
we don't know it's people what it what's
he putting up there satellites to
control his vast vehicle Army and our
minds this is why I've been so
complimentary see I'm the Benedict
Arnold here I I'm good if he when he
becomes the evil demon he's going to
remember me and he's gonna kill all of
you people yeah and I'm going to be like
this little Jester I'll sit on his lap
and I'll just go kill them kill them
Elon
all right
I really won't do that but it's good to
have a backup plan yeah hey Sean Hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to Fox
News YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else